turkey is presidential election will go
to a runoff later this month president
Richard erdogan took a five percent lead
over his main rival Kamel kilichtarulu
in Sunday's vote they will now face each
other once again on May 28th
now the governing Alliance of erdogan's
AK party and the Nationalist MHP have
retained power in Parliament The
People's Alliance won 322 seats while
the six-party opposition Nation Alliance
picked up
213. Hashem ahabara has more from Ankara
[Music]
has failed to win a presidential
election by a clear majority
but his supporters remain upbeat
we are very confident of getting the the
second round uh simply because there is
2.5
million vote gap between the closest
opponents erduran's rival Kamal
kilistarolu faces the complex task of
holding together the opposition Alliance
he promised to defeat erdoran and end
the justice and development parties
decades-long dominance of Turkish
politics losing the runoff would likely
be the end of his political career
erdogan erdogan didn't get the vote of
confidence he expected we don't win
elections by talking from balconies if
the nation says it to run off so be it
and we will win
the election was marred by allegations
the governing party was blocking ballot
counting in opposition strongholds
accusations the president dismissed
while telling supporters the vote was a
democratic exercise but International
observers warned suppressing Freedom
undermines democracy we have concern for
example when it comes to the media
situation the biased media situation
everything which is related to the free
speech and the possibility to get your
use forward so we have concerns which we
are
putting in our report synonym was an
outsider in the presidential race but
with five percent of the votes the
leader of the right-wing ancestral
Alliance could tip the scale
will have a bigger say in the runoff
there will be tough days ahead for us
but we will make sure that this process
is a good one for the nation and at this
time we won't say who we are going to
support
the stakes are high for both candidates
a win by erdogan would cement his legacy
his People's Alliance retained control
of parliament in Sunday's election
a defeat would mean the collapse of a
coalition of parties that put aside that
political differences for a common goal
the opposition Alliance had hoped to
make gains in areas devastated by the
earthquakes but despite widespread
criticism of the government's response
to the disaster it seems erdogan can
still rely on his support base in the
south east this leads the opposition
with limited options as they hope to
convince people to switch sides and vote
for their candidate Ankara
from Istanbul on the third place
candidates sinan Owen he won't be in the
runoff but his supporters could be vital
to the final result
he's already been talking about his
conditions for endorsement saying things
like hey you better not come and talk to
me unless you're willing first of all to
distance yourselves from those who calls
terrorists and that's understood to be a
reference to the pkk and some of the
Kurdish groups which are allegedly
political parties which are allegedly
associated with the pkk and he says the
other condition that you need to be able
to commit yourself to the expulsion of
refugees understood read into that
syrians from this country who are taking
up the jobs of Turks and this is the
issue
both sides whether it's the ruling
Coalition or the opposition Coalition
they both have nationalists within their
Coalition and they also have connections
or Coalition parties from the Kurdish
vote Block it's going to be interesting
to see who can woo those supporters of
sinan on more but here's the key Point
as well
if the second round goes along the lines
of the first one of course then Rajiv
taib erdogan has only a smaller
percentage that he needs to win over
then Commando of those nationalist
voters in order to cross the threshold